hi there me again now as the very famous  expert on language acquisition has said  stephen krashen  you need input you need a lot of the  language you don't have the language in  you you have to get it in you you get it  in you through a lot of listening and  reading but you have to take charge take  the time to understand how our system  works even if at first there seems to be  a lot of different functions take the  time it's worth it and then take the  time to find content lessons that you  find meaningful that you find enjoyable  if you choose something in the library  you don't like or something a lesson is  recommended to you that you don't like  do something else take the initiative  develop that that tendency to take the  initiative it's going to be the secret  to your success  find content that you like and listen  and read and listen and read and you'll  be surprised how your brain will get  used to the language good luck